good day everyone and welcome
i'm jack van horn from the university of
virginia please allow me to welcome you
to this edition of our 2020 2021
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series
this lecture is supported by the uva
integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain
institute
the college of arts and sciences the
school of data science and through a
grant from the national institutes of
general medical sciences
it is my privilege and my honor today to
welcome our speaker
dr gisele petzinger associate professor
of neurology from the keck school of
medicine
at the university of southern california
dr petzinger is a physician and board
certified neurologist
specializing in the care of patients
suffering from parkinson's disease
she divides her time between clinical
care for patients
and active laboratory research the
primary focus of dr petzinger's
laboratory is to better understand
how to promote brain repair resulting
from neurological syndromes
or following injury and should translate
these into new therapeutic treatments
dr petzinger has been involved with
numerous federally funded research
projects from the nih
the department of defense and notably
she serves as the principal investigator
on the u.s
army research grant entitled behavioral
and pharmacological enhancement of
neuroplasticity and basal ganglia
of the mptp lesioned mouse and in
non-human primates
dr petzinger's lecture today is entitled
investigating mechanisms of
exercise induced neuroplasticity in
cognitive motor systems in parkinson's
disease
translational studies and animal models
of pd to clinical research
as always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via youtube
if you're watching via youtube thank you
so much for joining us today
also our specially selected 2020 2021
biomedical data science innovation lab
participants
are encouraged to submit any questions
for dr petzinger via the chat feature in
their zoom sessions
i'll synthesize these questions and i'll
ask them on your behalf
in the last 10 minutes or so of the
lecture and with that welcome giselle we
are so excited to hear your lecture
excellent well thank you so much i'm
thrilled to be here and thank you uh dr
van horn for the invitation to
participate in the seminar series
um so i get to talk about
something that's obviously near and dear
to my heart which is parkinson's disease
um i'm going to just go through really
quickly what we're going to try to get
through in this hour
leaving 10 minutes for some questions at
the end i'm going to introduce parkins
disease and then talk about the field of
neural rehabilitation
and how that was brought to the field of
parkinson's
we'll then talk about neuroplasticity in
the context of exercise and use
our animal models as an example of
understanding these mechanisms
we're then dive into a very particular
problem in parkinson's
and that is cognitive problems and how
exercise may be helping that and then
we'll get into some mechanisms at the
end
that we're uh basically continuing to
investigate and are part of our current
study
so parkinson's disease is considered a
neurodegenerative disorder and
what that means is that there is an area
of cell loss what i'm showing here
is a normal brain in a parkinson's brain
and what we're pointing here
is the substantia [ __ ] pars compacta
which
are um contain melanin so you can see
them as a dark
matter in the in the midbrain and you
can see these tracks that go up and
reach into
uh what's called the basal ganglia the
caudate putamen and in parkinson's
disease we know that we lose about 60
of cells 80 of dopamine which starts
leading to the problems that we see
clinically uh parkinson's
is characteristically thought of as a
motor problem and what i mean by motor
i mean things like gait and balance
dysfunction
slowness uh tremor is not necessary
although people often
think about parkinson's as tremor but
certainly not necessary
probably the most important thing though
is gate balance and slowness
but we also touch upon some of the
non-motor features as it's relevant to
some of the studies that we're doing
and the big one that i'm going to spend
time talking about is something called
cognitive impairment
i'm just going to point out that
cognitive impairment um
in terms of dementia alzheimer's is the
most common form of dementia the second
probably is vascular the third is
parkinson's disease
uh cognitive impairment are is actually
very common in park disease and can be
seen
um in about 30 30 to 40 percent of
people within the first few years
of what we call mild cognitive parent uh
common question people
ask how common is parkinson's well it's
one in a hundred
one in a hundred uh individuals over the
age of fifty prevalence is about a
million in north america
so moving on um let's talk about
uh another aspect of parkinson's disease
that is not as well uh
recognized or at least not thought about
it but it's going to be very relevant
for the talk
that i'm about to give because one of
the challenges that we had and i'm going
to kind of walk you through what we went
through
initially when we were thinking about uh
what we say exercise induced
neuroplasticity
um you know the idea was that we were
very interested in thinking about it as
a circuit change right so
obviously people get interested in
knowing what it does for cells
for sure but the idea here was that
parkinson's disease is actually more
than a cell problem and that's the other
thing to really
emphasize as we move forward and i'm
just showing you as
an example two particular circuits these
particular circuits called the motor or
somatic motor somatosensory circuit
and the prefrontal striatal circuit or
both circuits that are involved for
example in motor movement
and the reason i'm pointing them out is
what people don't understand or realize
is that this particular circuit the
middle circuit in yellow
is another term another term we use for
this circuit is called the automatic
circuit
this is a circuit that's practiced that
over time
becomes um obviously
better stronger connections that
actually allows us to move through space
without having to think about it
but we also have this other circuit that
is involved
in processing um movement through space
it's also used for dual tasking this is
coming a circuit coming from the
prefrontal cortex of the basal ganglia
and this allows me to update information
about moving movement through space i'm
highlighting this just to keep in mind
as we move forward and think about what
we're doing with exercise
the idea is that in parkinson's disease
people actually have deficits the bigger
deficits is in this
automatic circuit so people start
requiring
more demand on this prefrontal cognitive
so a lot of what parkinson's
patients undergo when they're suffering
from from this slowness
is really a problem in automaticity
meaning they lose
automatic movements so they look and
appear slow and they have a higher
demand
on this cognitive process now this is
going to come up as i said again in our
discussion and the reason this is so
important is that this is one of the
reasons why people think there could be
some early cognitive changes
obviously don't mean depletion could be
contributing to this
but there is this other idea that maybe
uh you know with
this higher dependency on this
prefrontal cognitive circuitry maybe
there's some sort of saturation
that is making these patients more
vulnerable okay so to take home point
here
is obviously we know parkinson's disease
is fundamentally
involved in as a neurodegenerative
disease with dopamine
cell loss etc what i want to
again take home point it's also a
circuit problem and so this is going to
be important as we move forward
now the the next slide i'm showing you
is kind of the idea
of something that we're all appreciative
of which is uh
called neuroplasticity and this occurred
in the decade of the brain where people
were recognizing the importance of
neurogenesis that was ongoing as even in
aging um and also um basically the idea
that experiences that we um
we have in our day-to-day life um impact
uh
how our circuits are formed and we're
going to highlight some
specific ideas of that term again and
and we're going to come back to these
terms but i'm going to define them a
couple ways
because these are the sorts of ways that
we think about neuroplasticity in the
brain
i think the first point to make is very
important and that is
fundamentally it is how connections have
formed
brain reorganizes itself forming new
neural connections that are happening
through life
that itself is a natural aspect of what
we call neuroplasticity circuit
formation
um the other thing to keep in mind is
fundamentally this is happening at the
level of a synapse
so we're thinking about synaptic
structure and function
because both of them are relevant when
we think about plasticity the other
thing that's also important to keep in
mind and this comes up
when we think about things about uh how
things are changing in relationships to
other parts of the brain
which is something called homeostasis
which is that
neuroplasticity also probably underlies
aspects of the brain trying to reach a
new normal
so if there's one area of the brain
that's injured there's another brain
that's part of the brain that may be
taking up the slack
i would argue that what i just described
with parkins disease is an example of
that so they lose automaticity
they have to think more about moving in
space and that's a form of homeostasis
okay the last two points are going to be
particularly relevant when we talk about
exercise because again
very fundamentally neuroplasticity is
the way that we encode experiences
it's the way we code new behaviors and
in essence it's a way that the damaged
brain
we can basically have the areas of
damage
recover in response to rehabilitation
and the field that really took that
took uh that notion and really uh
began to use it practically in humans
really comes
from the spinal cord injury field and
actually the stroke field so
parkinson's disease came up much later
to this idea and by later i mean in the
last
15 years so this is another slide i
think it's you know
just a good slide to remind ourselves
that obviously we recognize how
important
experience dependent or plasticity is in
children we see these in athletes so
they
you know at the the top form of fluid
moving through space
but really where we're at now in the
field very much so is the idea that
we can harness these experiences and
provide them in a very deliberate way to
try to
kind of direct plasticity so we're
trying to see
areas of the brain that we think are
compromised how can we use
exercise to as a repair system and
importantly understand those mechanisms
that underlie that repair so we can
tap into that as well so when
when um i started getting into the field
uh so again this would be
um the early 2000 that long ago it
doesn't seem that long ago but it's been
that long
um basically one of the things that we
started seeing in parkinson's was this
idea
um that we could do more tapping into
gate and balance
problems and so most of the original
work
from parkinson's really came at trying
to recover
gait imbalance and um the reason i
i'm saying that is because i wanted to
again the idea of experience
that these physical therapists and these
particular exercises
that were being delivered we're really
trying to tap into some of the more
fundamental
points of parkinson's and um this
approach to the field that we had
was very different um i'm gonna i'm
going to juxtapose it to the
to the aging field aging field which
we'll talk about in just a second was
more interested in aerobic exercise but
because of parkinson's disease
the fundamental problem being with gate
imbalance you know if we're thinking
about neuroplasticity then you go
after recovery of that through these
different types of exercises
and one of the things that comes up
about it
often about thinking about all these
different exercises again what do they
have in common
and why do many of these different types
of exercise show the same benefits with
gate and balance which is what they've
done
um and one of the ideas that started
coming out of this discussion about
uh all these different types of
practices that could lead to improvement
was that they had um basically a
practice learning skill modality
fundamentally patients are getting
repetition they're getting feedback
to get better at gate and balance and so
that
what's coming out of the field then and
kind of getting a an understanding of
this approach
is in exercise for parkinson's disease
we were very much skill
goal oriented right out of the gate and
we saw some pretty amazing
improvements and i'm going to just show
you an example so this is a typical
patient with parkinson's and
the way again we characterize it is
slowness and
gait and balance you can see he's taking
a very short steps
and in just a moment here's going to
take even tinier steps
um we call this a context dependency
problem that they have
the idea that once they change even the
flooring it gets very hard for them to
to think about how to get through that
and so the steps actually get slower
um and so this is an example of an
individual who went through a gate and
balanced training
this was no change in medication at all
and so this sort of
response is what basically the
literature showed
that with practice particularly focused
on gait imbalance
you could definitely get pretty
significant gains in function
okay so this is again highlighting out
of the gate
what we became very interested in from
the field of parkinson's disease and
that is
exercise interventions that were
requiring practice that were specific to
the deficit
that were also difficult for the patient
in other words
we would progress them through harder
and harder practice
um so that they would get better right
and and keeping it complex
so this was interesting because many of
these thoughts that we were describing
really were borrowing from
the stroke field of spinal cord injury
field we were all talking the same
language
which is the idea of motor learning so
we were coming at it really from kind of
a motor learning point of view
um and and so when
we were trying to conceptualize how are
we going to study this and parkinson's
in
animal models right so we're now taking
what we're learning from humans and
we're thinking
okay what's the specific question we're
going to ask now about what
why these behaviors are better
fundamentally we started with the idea
of learning and and we talked about that
already so
the idea of learning of course is going
to happen right at a synapse so we
became very interested in really
tackling this question
do we see evidence for synaptic changes
synaptic plasticity
in the basal ganglia right and then the
second
factor not a small factor was kind of
all those other
things that are beneficial coming in
from from the body to the brain
right and and the aerobic field was
really taking off on this where the idea
is that blood flow
just you know get your get your heart
rate up get you know your body in shape
and all these factors would somehow make
it to the brain and then your brain
would be better so we
recognized that there were sort of these
juxtaposed ideas that were coming
uh you know in the field of exercise and
we were trying to reconcile that in our
in our brain about what does this really
mean and
uh and so the idea we we had come up
with was that
the idea is that something is happening
very locally within the brain in those
areas that are having problems deficits
basal basic angles and as an example
that right i pointed out about
problems in the automatic circuit as an
example prefrontal circuit is an example
but at the same time these factors that
may be coming in from the periphery may
be providing the environment
right so that if this repair is going to
happen synaptically
what may be coming in from the periphery
is support nor you know so a type of
um fertilizer if you will right that may
be supporting these types of synaptic
changes
okay so this is sort of another way to
think about it so
we were we were sort of here on the left
with parkinson's much more
skill and here's the heart field
right the idea of the the aerobic
exercise field the aging field that was
really tapping into the idea of
blood flow all right so we'll get back
to that in just a minute
um i'm just going to go on and we're
going to talk about animal models our
little joke here on translational and
hipaa hyper protection for our mouse and
our people
so here we have um an example of some
work that we
have done again this is in uh 2007.
um basically we started off with an mptp
rodent model
now there's a lot of um confusion in the
field
about how you design some studies with
mptp models
one of the things i wanted to point out
here because this is going to be
important
um we know after we give mptp so if we
lesion an animal
we know when all that cell death is
going to be done we actually know that
by five days
cell death is gone so if i'm using an
intervention
out here which is what we did we're not
looking at nerve protection this is not
a no protection study at all
this at this point is looking at a model
in which there's already cell death and
there's dopamine depletion so
think about it this way i'm looking at a
parkinson's patient okay
so i'm not trying to prevent cell death
i'm trying to see
in this animal model that is already
have deficits
can i do anything to that brain now so
this would be a nor restorative model
okay so with that in mind we have these
two groups of animals these are our
parkinsonian mptp animal
that i said have completed cell death so
we know already they're parkinsonian and
here's our healthy control
and we basically have them in exercise
and no exercise groups on both sides
okay and so this is basically the
original
um this is some of the original
treatment work that we did and um you
can see
these animals actually get up to pretty
high speeds now
you can argue that most of this is
aerobic which is true
but um if you don't know a mouse
obviously most mice are not running in a
direction like this and certainly not
heading towards a wall
so we did feel that this angle obviously
had to have
some prefrontal uh circuits activated
here to be able to attend to the task
and concentrate on what it needed to do
to make sure it didn't hit
the back end and get sacked so there is
aspects of
certainly intentional control um what i
want to show you here
is basically the original paper that was
really a paper focused on neural
restoration
there had been already one other paper
out there using a similar model to us
who had looked at nerd protection so
again
just to make these uh juxtapose these
two different ideas
in this case they're parkinsonians so
what i'm looking for is improvement in
behavior
and what we see here is uh after we have
had the animals
run uh for about uh four weeks weekends
off
uh we see that these animals get better
so here in the dark
uh black is sailing here's the mptp
animal and so here we see an exercise
group that parkinsonian animals in fact
get better
and it's kind of like no surprise now if
i practice skill i'm going to get better
at skill and we're certainly able to
demonstrate that in a mouse
but what was surprising to us were a
couple other things that came out of
that
and one of the things that came out that
we thought was so important was when we
looked at total dopamine levels so we
talked about dopamine and how dopamine
is depleted
right so we can see that in this mptv
animal here's the black bar here's your
dopamine depletion
our parkinsonian animal and our control
you can see it's quite depleted
in the mouse what's surprising to us
though was when we saw
exercise uh so this is after the animal
finished exercise
we didn't see any recovery of dopamine
and that becomes very important because
it kind of helped us kind of secured our
thoughts which was
we were interested in circuitry we were
interested to know
something downstream what was happening
downstream
that may be relevant for driving these
effects because
the tendency was to think if i am
improving
and parkinson's i must have some element
of neurogenesis
or i must have some sort of dopamine
recovery and that is not the case
at least not in this type of
experimental design and that
again pulled us out of the niagara and
now into the circuitry to start looking
more specifically what's happening there
now what we were able to do though is we
were able to look at release of doping
and this is
a basically a physiological approach
called voltometry
all i'm showing you here is a slice of a
brain and all these different areas of
places where we introduce the needle
and we excite that area and look for
dopamine release take home point is way
down here what we're showing you here is
what's in hatched or exercised animals
in all those different positions i'm
showing you in the basal ganglia up here
and in dark gray is a non-exercise you
can see
anywhere that i excite i'm getting more
doping release so
take home not changing the amount of
doping but absolutely changing the
properties of the dopamine meaning that
they're being released
the other thing that we saw i'm just
going to slide down to here
is to show you that we didn't see any
changes in cell number
so no there is no evidence of
neurogenesis
with exercise and we've never seen that
in in our model
uh basically there's so what what i'm
trying to say is whatever change that
i've
shown you so far it's basically in
release properties
uh this slide up here it's just a
take-home point to say that we're also
seeing
in dark uh gray is our ability to to
image
uh the transport of domain which is a
reuptake system and actually the
transport system goes down meaning
don't mean it's not being taken back up
in fact it's being left out in the
synapse so
this is homeostasis this is a perfect
example
of homeostasis and it matches the ideas
of neuroplasticity
okay so what else did we learn and i'll
try to move a little quickly here
um we also learned that we were changing
dopamine receptors in the basal ganglia
d2 is a very critical
one for motor control here's your mptp
parkinsonian animal
we saw it go up with exercise but more
importantly
was being able to translate that into an
image and
what we were able to do was use a
falapride f-18
pride um to be able to see whether or
not we had
d2 receptive changes within the stratum
and the take-home message as we were
so this is a superimposed pet image with
uh an mri image of a mouse
and here we have d2 phallopride um in
red
and here we have it in a parkinsonian
state d2 regulation
or d2 expression going down and then
with exercise d2
is up we were particularly interested in
using phala pride because radklpride
which you
some people may be familiar with is
actually probably a better measure for
dopamine amount
uh and we didn't want to look at domain
amount we were interested specifically
on the d2 receptor
uh f18 thalapride was a um designed by a
chemist at
uc irvine um and he was able to help us
uh execute this study so take home point
is that we see release of dopamine and
we see an increase in dopamine receptors
although we see no change in total
dopamine levels
or cell number we're also able to
replicate this
in a much smaller study in parkinson's
patients so
that uh study that we talked about in
the very beginning you know we talked
about all these different types of
exercises one of the exercises that we
really got involved in
uh which i don't have to a time to show
you pre-post videos
of that was a treadmill study so we
basically put patients on treadmill
these were newly diagnosed patients
with parkinson's on no medication at all
um
because you and i both know that
medication can sometimes affect some of
these tracers
so we had patients on no medication we
put them through eight weeks of exercise
and what you're seeing here is a pre
post
actually it's a post minus pre d2 scan
here's again superimposed here's your
pet scan with d2
here's our mri and this is a super super
imposed
pet on on a um mri image
just to show you how sensitive that
dialopride is to the stratum
and here's your this is actually the
most important picture which is 1d
what you're seeing in red is a
subtraction of post-exercise
from pre-exercise to show that what we
saw in animals was also true
in humans um and so that again
showing how important uh exercise was
and actually just
changing just the local dynamics of
dopamine within that stratum so again
we're downstream of the nigel system
we're actually within the basal ganglia
um another aspect of neurotransmission
that we're interested in is actually
something called glutamate
for those of you who study uh synaptic
structure and function you know
how important glutamate is in terms of
regulating
the functional aspects of the synapse so
i'm just showing you a cartoon drawing
of a synapse that is happening within
the striatum so these are
going to be glutamatergic inputs coming
in from the cortex
so here we have here and on the
postsynaptic side are what we call
medium spiny neurons and that's really
what makes up the bulk of the stratum
so i'm showing you a synapse and what
i'm showing you in cartoon image here is
a number of very different important
facets that we saw
change within the glutamatergic system
with exercise and one thing we saw is
in mbtp what's interesting and what's
been reported is when dopamine depletion
occurs you actually have a build up of
this glutamatergic system
it gets very hypoxidable we call it
increased glutamatergic drive
it's aberrant it actually leads to
average behavior
so we have in one aspect we have loss of
synapses within the striatum
but in those remaining synapses we have
this buildup of glutamate we see a lot
of glutamate pre-synaptically we can use
em this was
how we looked at that em shows high
levels of glutamate here
and post-synaptically we could see a
build up of glutamate postsynaptically
and that's um
what we see here in white um and then
with exercise we saw
it normalized so that's the take home
point glutamate which is
typically thought of as
hyperglutamatergic in the parkinsonian
state
we saw it normalized with exercise so
again further evidence
that in fact we are seeing um
homeostatic changes really so we're
driving
i'm going to pull through that get
through this um some pretty significant
players in terms of neurotransmitters
within the striatum itself and
um a lot of that work we ended up taking
on into the prefrontal
circuit as well prefrontal cortex in
particular and were able to replicate
a lot of what i just showed you there in
the stratum so another very important
point that people don't realize
is here's a medium spiny neuron right
here we've blown this up
and uh we're going to take a look at
this medium spin on the neuron because
what we're particularly interested in is
all these little thorny things
happening off to the side these are
synapses and um
and remember again if as i mentioned if
you're interested in plasticity at
fundamentally you do want to get at the
level of the synapse and that's why we
do these animal studies
so what i'm showing you here down below
is a blown up version of this just to
show you the number of contacts
these medium spine neurons are as i told
you that coming from the cortex
the cortical striatal input is pretty
big so is the thalamic striatal input
and basically they provide a
glutamatergic tone on that median spinal
neuron
i told you that when dopamine depletion
occurs
we saw we saw changes in glutamate
neurotransmission i said it went up
but we also see loss of contact so you
can see that so there's actual
disintegration if you will we see loss
of synapses
within the stratum so that's such an
important point because
again i think one of the issues that
often comes up is people
have this idea that everything is
happening down in the midbrain
the truth is a lot of the action is
hopping upstream
at the level of circuitry and and so
this is again just a perfect example of
why we need to be focused on circuitry
in parkinson's and
um also i'm going to just show you one
other uh this is again another
meetings finding neuron this was work
done by bill toy in the lab
uh he basically was able to trace a 3d
image looking at these medium spinning
neurons
and what i want to show you to the right
is just examples of
animals uh basically a selected uh
cartoon if you will filled cells just to
show you how different the arborization
looks
of these cells so here we have a normal
animal this is a medium-spinning neuron
within this within the
stratum here's an mptp animal this is
dopamine depletion guys
look how different that looks right
that's so you can see actually
lots of loss of dendritic garberization
right here and here's exercise
so yeah that's pretty important because
again it you know if everything holds
true in the universe
this animal model is telling us how
important it is
that we look at circuitry and synapses
i'm not disregarding the importance of
dopamine but what i'm telling you is
that this
is key because it's going to give us
some new therapeutic angles to go after
okay so um how about counting spines so
this is again
more work with from bill toy in the lab
and i'm trying to show you here's
how we go about doing this this is a
golgi stain of the dorsal stratum the
dorsal stratum is
within the basal ganglia it's the most
important motor aspect of the basal
ganglia here it is filled with
golgi and so what we can do what bill
did really
uh was he basically counted he counted
all these synapses so you can see with
exercise we actually see some increase
even in normal animals which is good to
know so you don't need parkinson's to
get benefit from exercise
but here we have with mptp we see some
stripping and here we have mptp exercise
and
and this paper um came out in 2011
basically showing evidence for
synaptogenesis taken point then
in parkinson's disease we have not seen
neurogenesis
and this is a model where we have
created a parkinsonian animal right it's
not a neuroprotective model
it's already a parkinson's animal now
when we
apply exercise to that animal what we do
see is evidence for
repair homeostasis neuroplasticity and
synaptogenesis
we don't talk neurogenesis at least not
within the basal ganglia
and [ __ ] not in our pd field now there
are some evidence for hippocampal and
people hear about that neurogenesis
but in areas that we're particularly
interested in it's for us
it really is more about synaptogenesis
that we're interested in
okay so let's change uh directions a
little bit and let's talk
now about the different types of
exercises that we kind of talked about
from the beginning right we said
in the parkinson's field we're coming at
it from skill base we want to get this
gate and balance
effect um but the truth is there's a lot
out there about aerobic exercise and
we were interested in understanding does
it matter what i
do particularly if i'm interested in
getting at some of these other circuits
like the prefrontal circuit
can i tap into that system because well
it's a problem in parkinson's disease
and daniel hostetter in the lab came up
with a really nice
way to study this and and by the way for
those who don't know what skill based
exercise this is things like yoga tai
chi pretty much any type of structured
exercise that you can think of
and then aerobic exercise we think of as
getting more your heart rate up
so this would be examples of running
swimming cycling that sort of thing and
here's
just examples of that not the not kind
of unusual examples
i don't know we thought that was kind of
cool okay so here we go so the
difference here is we have animals
both of these animals have these running
wheels and these wheels are on
motorized rods so they are definitely
getting the aerobic practice
without a doubt but the difference
between these different
running wheels as you can see is one has
spokes removed and one does not
and and so what we were trying to do
here what what dr holsteiner
particularly was trying to do was try to
tap into the idea of
how important is it to be engaged in
what you're doing can you just be
running or getting your heart rate up or
having that extra benefit is that
something that could be relevant
um and so what he did was he put those
animals through those
running wheels for about six weeks and
he has
his background is being able to do
cerebral blood flow mapping he does that
by using this particular
dye c4 c14 iodo
uh antipyrene and so after the animals
have finished exercise he
he keeps them uh perfused um
with this dye and basically after that
perfusion is done
this the brain is removed put on on film
and we can do a type of parametric
mapping like we do
in humans so this is
looking at those two groups of animals
now you can see
uh what what dr schneider did was put a
seed in one of those areas of prefrontal
cortex to see what else is being
connected to that area once that area is
seeded
and the comparison is again between the
non-skill and the skilled
and what was kind of cool about this was
that it seemed to suggest that
it did matter that blood flow uh
seemed to suggest that yes the more
cognitively engaged that you're
that you are in the task um you can
change at least
uh regional cerebral blood flow and we
we believe
that that is a marker of neural activity
that's part of the ongoing studies that
we're doing right now is to begin to
understand
what is underlying that effect evidence
for andiogenesis
and also neuronal synaptogenesis
so back to this story then um let's talk
a little bit more about uh more
specifically about aerobic exercise
and what i decided to do um you know so
we had already done some work with
skilled exercise and
i given the fact that the aerobic
exercise field physically cognitive
aging had shown
so many of these incredible facts with
um cognition
particularly executive function which is
what we're interested prefrontal cortex
is executive function
and memory uh decided to go ahead and
see if we could take a look at that in
patients with parkinson's disease and so
what we decided to start off with was
just a cross-sectional study so
no intervention just patients that we
knew were already active were recruited
into the study
this was 48 patients and this is sort of
a breakdown of their age so about 64
years of age
uh slightly higher um more more
more men than females which is more men
than women which is actually very common
and parkinson's
there's slightly a higher incidence of
parkinson's in men than women
it's also easier to recruit men in
general most studies
um and then the years of diagnosis is
about 10 10 years of diagnosis we looked
at some aspects of fitness our
particular interest was this one this is
a way that we can look at
cardiorespiratory fitness so people talk
about do2max
so cardiorespiratory fitness has a lot
of different kinds of ideas behind it
but one idea is that
it's sort of reflective of blood flow as
well so it obviously vo2 max is
how well i'm extracting oxygen but
people also use it sort of
as a surrogate if you will of how much
blood i'm getting
into the brain so i'm i'm pointing out a
couple
uh aspects of parkinson's that we i
mentioned before that we're interested
in
um i didn't particularly mean to
highlight this but
memory memory is definitely one of them
uh so it is
uh not just unique to alzheimer's but we
definitely see pd executive function
though i would say is quite big
visual spatial so executive function is
a prefrontal system
visual spatial function which is my
ability to navigate through crowds
uh attention processing speed all of
these are
actually pretty common deficits that we
can see even early in parkinson's
disease
and so what we were able to show in this
um
let me go oops yeah
so i'm just going to highlight quickly
some very uh points
on this particular study um i'm going to
show first of all we were
we did take uh in with the mri we were
able to to segment the brain and do some
free surfer
analysis with our patients with heart
disease and this is just a cartoon
to show a couple areas that we saw some
hits with cardio respiratory fitness we
saw it with thalamus and pallidum
which is a little surprising but i'm
going to show you some data that may
explain that
and then we also saw with a couple of
these domains so we saw again in this
cross-sectional study
a very significant association between
executive function episodic memory and
visual spatial
so it is lining up with what they're
reporting in
aging um what's different for us is uh
the uh alzheimer's field reports in
structural changes in the hippocampus
um so they see a relationship between
cardiorespiratory fitness and the
hippocampus
and prefrontal and we saw it uh in the
thalamus and the pallidum
and again i'll i'll tell you why we
think that is in just a second
um the other point of this paper this
paper is hopefully coming out soon
and parkinsonism-related disorders it's
being submitted right now
but the point is what i also want to
show is we were able to look at some
mediation analysis here
all this is it's a mediation analysis
where we try to see whether the effects
of vo2 on things like episodic memory
or vo2 and executive function can be
explained by
volumetrics in thalamus and are
basically we were able to show that in
fact it was explaining this
okay so i mentioned to you that i would
say something about why thalamus it was
an unexpected finding
so what i'm going to just highlight is
another paper again uh hol schneider
dr holshonder our group who had done
some studies looking at
exercise um and uh more particularly uh
using the same blood flow technique
um basically able to show that actually
with aerobic exercise we
are seeing uh quite a bit of activation
within the thalamus and there's two
areas in particular
that we're seeing changes in the cm and
the ventral lateral aspects
these are a particular interest because
actually these areas are very much
uh interconnected with the prefrontal
cortex lots of
data out in parkinson's in fact about
the latex changes
that occur uh with cognitive impairment
um
so uh stay tuned but yes lots now coming
out more and more on the on
how important the thalamus is and how
the thalamus really works with the
prefrontal system um to help
with executive function and the same
also is true for for memory
okay so um let me just keep going so
mechanisms
that we are interested at looking at now
that we've got some
obviously some interesting data uh i
i've told you that there was
already a lot published with with um
balance and gate with parkinson's
the cognitive field is still something
up for debate it's been mostly studied
in aging but there are
a number of studies that have come out
uh two studies particularly
aerobic exercise where they've sung some
changes
with ef our study was different because
we looked at cardiorespiratory fitness
that hasn't really
been looked at that way uh in our
parkinson's disease but we're seeing
definitely some association there so
we're excited that we're seeing
something similar to what's been
reported in aerobic exercise as well
but the question still remains um why do
we care what what
is underlying these effects how can we
better understand that
and i'm just listing you know a couple
things that we're particularly
interested in i'm going to point out
uh some very specific factors that we're
looking at obviously neurotrophic
factors is way up there
but as i mentioned um you know
angiogenesis and blood flow is also
critical for us
um uh because um the some of the
original work
uh that was done in animal models where
we saw exercise effects on the brain
this is
a study that was done by green l and
black
back in the 70s basically showed how
important angiogenesis was
um in animal behavior so we're trying to
look at angiogenesis as well
um so in thinking about that um
one of the things um so let's talk about
trophic factors first
we got interested in looking at one
particular cell of the brain that
is probably one of the most important
cells that
uh is important for neurotrophic factor
delivery and more importantly
for support of neuronal support and this
these are actual
astrocytes so what's kind of cool about
the astrocytes is they
have a way not only to tap into blood
vessels so
uh all the small capillaries they're
they're lying up against
but they they also have very strong
connections to synapses right and we
talked about how important synapses are
so astrocytes became very important for
us because we were interested to see
uh what role they may play in providing
support
number one but number two they're also a
a venue or a a supplier if you will of
no trophic factors
so um one of our graduate students in
the lab began to look at astrocytes
um in animals and began to look at them
and these two very specific areas were
interested in the prefrontal cortex and
the stridem
um and what he was able to show with
exercise was
this pretty impressive arborization
that's happening with
astrocytes uh just through exercise
the other thing he was able to
demonstrate was so
one of the things we knew that
astrocytes did
was not only provide trophic support but
actually provide
a fuel to the synapses and one important
source of fuel believe it or not
um is actually lactate so where does
lactate come from well lactate comes
from the periphery lactate is certainly
upregulated with exercise
so we wanted to find a way to see what
lactate what role lactate may play
um in this effect of exercise so to step
back for a second if i imagine that i'm
exercising
i imagine that i got i have some lactate
buildup that's being delivered to the
astrocytes
the question is what and how is
astrocytes responding to this
so here's the study that was done by
adam uh lundqvist in the lab
and here are some astrocytes that he put
lactate on
up he pulled them from the brain and
what we're showing here is just a number
of neurotrophic factors
um that he was able to measure in these
cultures and basically what we're
highlighting here are some big ones
gd and f and bdnf are very commonly
described neurotrophic factors
particularly in exercise field as an
example
we can see that actually with the
administration of lactate these
astrocytes
from the brain are in fact making
trophic factors so
that is again as we unders try to
understand how synapses are
uh remodeling both functionally and
structurally
astrocytes may play a very important
role as we would anticipate
given its role in synaptic structure
maintenance
and repair i think the other uh thing
that was also
um important was that he repeated this
study in a live animal so
the other study was done in culture but
he was able to show when he lacked when
he administered
lactate to animals he was also able to
and take out the animal brain
again he was able to replicate what he
saw in cell culture which is an increase
here we go
these are beating bdnf and and cntf gdnf
that it is absolutely it's upregulated
in the brain and he was also able to
show again
in uh in vivo's study that this that uh
we saw
a growth in the astrocytic morphology as
well
okay so changing tracks again
so here we are understanding
what is causing repair to occur picking
one cell
as an important cell astrocytes one
possibility
is lactate coming in from the periphery
maybe
uh helping these astrocytes not only
provide fuel so astrocytes can deliver
lactate
to the cell but also play a role in
trophic support
how about the immune system we tend to
think about the immune system
as bad obviously with covid going on we
all think of it as bad
but it turns out as you know that
everything has good parts and bad parts
so we were interested in looking at the
good parts of the immune system and what
we decided to do
was first and foremost was to take a
look at whether or not
there was any evidence for immune cells
coming into the brain
um i'm going to uh walk you through this
kind of busy slide so bear with me for
just a second
first of all we're using the mouse model
of parkinson's again this was work done
by brett lund
uh in our group and one of the questions
that we were trying to ask
was uh looking at another important cell
within the brain
it's called microglia it's equivalent in
the periphery are called mononuclear
cells
so while the majority of uh so in
microglia
another cell that can provide trophic
support it's also very important for
repair
it is the innate immune system of the
brain
um what's kind of cool about this is
that people for a long time
felt that there was um basically some
immune privilege in the brain meaning
that there was no
interchange with the periphery um but
that now
that idea has now gone away and now
people are accepting yes
actually there are some peripheral
mononuclear cells
that can go into the brain and change
phenotype to become now look like
microglial cells
so the reason we did this study was we
were interested in understanding
was there any contribution from the
immune system and particularly cells
coming in from the periphery to the
brain in an exercise animal taken point
is yes
and the way this was done was basically
looking at surface markers
that we knew existed on peripheral
mononuclear cells
and we can use what's called a facts
analysis to actually
measure the presence of these cells and
so what you're seeing
circled in red is our analysis looking
for the
presence of these cells now in the brain
the way we do that is
we're going to have these four different
groups of animals after they complete
their tasks we're going to take the
brain out this is taking the whole brain
out
and we're going to start we emulsif we
separate out cells and we start looking
for these purple mononuclear cells which
i said we can track
because we have we know what to look for
on the cell surface
and i'm going to show you here here's an
mptp animal that has
gone through no exercise the same model
they're going through the treadmill
just like i showed you from the very
beginning so basically four weeks of
exercise
or part of me up to six weeks of
exercise so here's mptp no exercise here
we go two weeks
boom coming in from the periphery guys
six weeks
boom even more isn't that cool that's
wild
yeah so here and this is just
quantitative so yes
it does seem like peripheral mononuclear
cells can come into the periphery and so
the whole idea that
and we toy with this not uncommonly i
mean what does
alterations of blood-brain barrier
really mean you know we again
you know nothing is dichotomous i mean
it's not all
bad or you know it's so the idea is that
there's
there could be some important aspects of
changes in barbarians
in this case some aspects that are
actually allowing mononuclear cells to
come in now you would ask yourself
are you doing something bad to this
brain and the answer to that
was also answered in the next slide so
what we're showing here in a little cute
cartoon here is basically this is the
this is the exercise non-exercise
and what we looked at were both pro and
anti-inflammatory markers and
these are the pro-inflammatory and these
are anti-inflammatory we wanted to know
whether in general the cells that i just
showed you
in that brain we can extract them and
then we actually
um cause them we activate them we can
use
something uh anagen to basically
activate these cells to start secreting
what they what they typically make to
bring it out more
and so what we're able to demonstrate in
these same cells
was an increase in neurotrophic factors
and anti-inflammatory so it's an
anti-inflammatory markers here's
also showing that these ones that would
be considered problematic are down
regulated so
take home point is in the mptp exercise
in white
we're seeing clear evidence that these
cells coming in are not bad
these cells that are coming in with
exercise are providing
some trophic support um
okay so
i'm going to um end right there
with some take-home points um that
um we that we talked about at this at
this uh
seminar and then i'll also talk very
briefly what we're planning to do where
we're going from here
but basically the idea is absolutely
multiple types
of exercise seem to be important but
maybe for different reasons so
i i think the idea that um obviously
we're still interested in aerobic
exercise but skill exercise
um still plays a role here and it may be
that skilled exercise may be tapping
into more
motor aspects of movement if you will um
and that aerobic may be more cognitive
um
i think the other thing when we talk
about looking for evidence for
plasticity i
i hope i tried to convince you that yes
i mean we do think
whatever the effects of these exercises
are on in parkinson's we very much think
that it's happening within a circuit um
and again not to dismiss the importance
of dopamine but we do
feel that with the animal data it's
strongly supporting synaptic
restructuring
um and both morphological and functional
changes that we're seeing
um in terms of what's driving this these
are studies that are ongoing right now
we are currently
um looking at a number of different
immune factors in
our a big dod study that's going on
right now
department of defense this is actually
jack van van horn
and siva uh vancadish who are helping us
to look at
structural and functional changes in
imaging
over an 18-month period baseline and in
18 months
and we're also looking to see how this
relates to some immune factors that
we've looked at in
in animals we're going to see how that
relates to the humans um we're also
looking
for uh changes in uh and a number of
neurotrophic factors as well
so um i'm gonna
end with this slide um i just want to
remind you it takes a village
i'm fortunate very fortunate um that i
get to work with a lot of really great
people
this is a big list and again we just
joined is siva
and jack van horn duck van horn which
we're thrilled uh to partner with
uh at university of virginia and then uh
michael jackwick a pi uh
co-pi here at usc don scheisse ucsd dan
holstein who i mentioned
as well who's uh basically here at usc a
big co-pi of this study
and brett lund here with a lot of the
immune data um also adam lundqvist who
did a lot of the work with the
astrocytes
has been particularly important and that
we have another grad student aaron
donahue who will be helping quite a bit
with the immune factors
um i thank you so much for allowing me
to present this as i said i i work with
an amazing team and
just to emphasize again it's all about
finding a great team to work with i
can't emphasize that enough and uh
in any event i'm happy to take any
questions thank you so much gisele that
was a fantastic
tour de force of all the current
thinking in
parkinson's disease research um a couple
of questions so i was really intrigued
uh
i've always been intrigued about uh the
role of the thalamus here
um it just it is the sort of the router
of
the brain and uh given the emphasis you
put on circuitry
um i'm kind of curious a little more
about the thalamus
um whether or not these are you know
what are these um nuclei that are
the ones that you're focused on or the
ones that like the results have borne
out
are do these tend to be more association
nuclei relay nuclei
are they interlaminar um do you have a
sense
you know right now not not really we
actually i mean that
data was actually surprised to us we
have not really paid attention too much
of the thalamus
it was because of this the findings that
we just showed you and then looking back
at some of the work that daniel
host under did that we began to see oh
my gosh there's a lot
there that we need to start looking at i
mean i think um
people certainly appreciate the role
more so now
um although mike would argue that that
that people have been looking at it from
for a number of years
but um its role in cognition i would
still say is relatively new there's not
that much out there
on it um so you know all those
those are all great questions we simply
don't know i i can say though that um
you know again if you look at some of
the imaging data out there
not not a lot of functional imaging but
structural imaging um
that there are definitely reports of at
least volume loss there
and um both regionally and globally
in the thalamus um i would also say that
you know prior to
um most of the work in thalamus as you
may already know has really been focused
on motor
so again cognition is going to be kind
of relatively new and
not that much out there so i think
hopefully you and and steve are going to
help us with that
answer that question right um one thing
which
you touched on it in a couple of
different places in your talk is
um that being bdnf uh players to have
some
direct relationship to exercise uh gdnf
as well and other neurotrophic factors
and i'm curious about their role in
cognition
um kind of more specifically but then
also how um
specific are some of these effects in
parkinson's disease and are there other
implications for other
neurodegenerative disorders yeah i mean
i think
again that's that is a great question i
mean i think first of all people have
looked at
bdnf um in uh parkinson's models and
have definitely seen
some changes in bdnf expression within
the stridom i think one of the questions
that often comes up
is how relevant is bdnf expression in
the periphery particularly just
measuring it
and i think that's a little bit why we
got interested in looking at cells
um because the idea is that bdnf may not
cross
and there's but but for example immune
cells may
and that may be the more important
driver uh i think the other thing is
what
cells may be making locally that may be
important here as well
and again that's the astrocyte and the
microglia both of which
could contribute to to know some
neurotrophic factor support
um i think the question though that
comes up is you know
kind of how specific regionally specific
are these effects
um we don't know i mean we we'd like to
think that they are regionally specific
we like to think that some of this
may be uh circuit specific um maybe
because of blood flow
you know that changes fundamental
changes in angiogenesis is really what's
driving these effects
so wherever you're seeing angiogenesis
is where most of these effects are
happening we believe
and and we believe that because um one
thing that i i didn't get a chance to
show was that
um we are seeing some transcript
expression from
from um transcripts that are important
in in angiogenesis
um and uh neurotropic factor expression
that are coming from neurons
so um the the idea that
the neurons that are being activated
through the process of whatever you're
doing let's say
running or you know processing
information the idea that neuronal
activation
may be driving some of these circuit
specific effects so
the periphery isn't creating it it's the
actual use
of the brain how you're using your brain
if you will the fact that i'm
being more cognitively aware of what i'm
doing and again just to point to
the very specific example that i showed
you with daniel
where you know clearly these two animals
were both aerobically
challenged but the idea that one animal
was actually
much more engaged uh can actually change
blood circuitry right so at least by the
by by that particular method
suggests that there may be something
about
exactly what we said how i'm using my
brain how
engaged i am that that may influence
some of these effects
how transferable are the uh
results you're finding in mice to humans
you know that's a great question you
know so i as you can see i'm a big
animal believer and i often find you
know you you you know you it's really
all about the question and and the
limitations
of your model and understanding your
model quite a bit we've i've worked in
the model for a very long time so
you know we're not in any way shape or
form saying that this is parkinson's
disease
but what i think it does is it really
gives us an example
of uh plasticity and and we've certainly
been able to demonstrate that
in an animal right and and show that um
again with very little changes and don't
mean you're already getting quite a bit
of downstream activation happening
and we've been pretty fortunate in being
able to replicate some of these findings
as you can see for example d2
uh we were able to replicate that in
humans and that was the first study of
that wasn't an animal
an amputee an mptp mouse that's how we
learned that that wasn't human that was
an animal
the second thing how we learned we
learned you know is i talked about this
increased release of dopamine
that was just replicated by john stossel
at university of british columbia
he actually used uh i think he did use
recopy to demonstrate
that there was more dopamine be released
replicating what we first described in
the animal
um so i've we're hedging our bets that
you know it's a good model
when you have a very specific question
that you want to ask
um and then of course you know thinking
about how you how you translate and ask
that specific question in humans
but as you know i mean the study we're
doing right now in the dod is totally
because of this animal data
including the immune factors you know
we're not looking only at i mean we're
not just looking at immune factors in
the blood we're looking at cells for the
reasons that we talked about right the
idea that we do think
that there could be some of these cells
migrating into the into the brain
and began and looking to see what
they're making is also very important
part of this study
so women are hard to find now is it
because there's just a difference in the
diagnostic rate of parkinson's disease
in women or are
males just more likely to want to
participate in these things
and if if that's the case have you
noticed any sex differences that might
be between males and females with and
without pd yeah that
that's a great question so you know in
parkinson's there's a slightly higher
incidence of parkinson's and males and
in alzheimer's you know it's just the
reverse it's slightly higher in women
um honestly it's it's pretty common for
many studies to
to get more men than women although in
our current dod study we're actually
about 50 50. i i really worked hard to
make sure we got
a substantial number of women um in
terms of
um you know people have looked at some
gender differences between men and women
and
you know there have been some
suggestions for example you know maybe
men may be a little bit more um
likelihood for
for having more problems with their
parkinson's specifically things like
more cognitive issues
as an example but the truth is it's
still relatively understudied
um so it's not a very yeah not as much
information out
out there with with parkinson's and
women there's some
but not not that much so hopefully these
are some of the questions that we can
try to address in our group
i can say that you know in looking at
some of the you know exercise activities
um we we have women you know we've we've
been looking at a lot of different
parameters of exercise including
intensity
and you know um again this is an
exercise group that we're looking at and
i was curious
uh because we you know we're seeing some
really nice data with some intensity uh
and wearables whether those were all men
and actually it's about 50 50 men and
women so
um it's nice to see that our women group
are as active as men i'm not surprised
but uh interestingly some other types of
exercise parameters that i think will be
of interest
for us to look at a little bit more
closely is back to that vo2
max as an example of cardio respiratory
fitness one of the things we do know
is that a couple things influence that
is the the our
our ability to get that fitness level up
as measured through vo2 max
aging will flatten that out a bit and
women tend to be a lot further um
just are not able to get up to that
level of cardio respiratory fitnesses
men do
as measured through vo2 max so it you
start seeing some sex
differences um there um on some of these
metrics particularly vo2 max that's
that's actually known
um and we hope to be able to explore
that a little bit i'm also hoping that
we're looking at some uh estrogen
replacement questions and this as well
where we're going to be following and
tracking that
as well with cognition people have
looked at that and and there's data both
ways
whether or not estrogen is helpful or
not helpful in parkinson's disease for
women
one final thing is one thing that's
striking about
your presentation is just the different
types of data
that you are gathering to look at
parkinson's disease
uh whether it's you know at the
molecular level you're looking at these
neurotrophic factors you're looking at
pet imaging you're looking at you know
connectivity modeling
you know across spatial and temporal
scales how important are
the computational approaches and the
kind of the integration of this data
um to being to getting that
comprehensive view of parkinson's
disease
yeah i mean i think that's that's well
that's why you're you're joining us jack
you're going to help us with that
because i think as you can see
you know it has kind of this puzzle feel
to
it doesn't it i mean we've got kind of
kind of different ideas of what's
happening in terms of the noon uh in
terms of angiogenesis
um even with behavior and the idea is to
try to
find a common thread particularly given
the fact that
at the end of the day we are interested
in circuit specific effects
and um you know trying to think about
that spatially as well where some of
these bigger
effects are happening i think that will
be particularly important because again
that will help us guide the animal data
in terms of where we really need to be
diving down and looking for some of
these molecular changes so
um yeah i think a computational approach
will help us
without a doubt really focus in and
eliminate things
that may be epi phenomenon but are not
nearly as critical as some of these
other points we've talked about that a
lot you get a lot of data but the
question is what which ones are the
relevant ones and
and uh being able to hone in on those
are certainly helped by a computational
approach
fantastic and with that thank you gisele
petzinger from
university of southern california we
really appreciate you sharing your work
with us today
um what an exciting project really
fantastic talk thank you so much
everybody who's out there listening
thank you so much for for joining us
today
and uh we'll look forward to seeing you
next week excellent thanks so much guys
you guys take care bye bye now
bye